texas governor greg abbott now joins us
and sir good morning to you
specific question has the state of texas
asked whether or not they could
talk to these migrants to get more
information from them
as to whether or not they've been
subjected to traffickers along the way
i have so i made a direct plea to the
bite administration a couple of days ago
for texas and are professionals in this
state that
deal with human trafficking all the time
to have access to these minors who
have come across the border to learn
more about how they were trafficked here
and then we received word yesterday from
the bite administration that
they would allow no such thing because
they want to continue the cover-up the
cover-up that you've been talking about
there are two things that the
administration is trying to hide from
the american public
one is the massive number of people
who are coming across the border and the
bind administration's
lack of preparation to deal with this
massive number
the second thing they want to hide is
this and that is that with every person
coming across the border
it empowers and it enriches the drug
cartels
who are involved in every single person
coming across the border
including these young children these
young children coming across the border
are victims of human trafficking
somebody has to get to the bottom of it
that's exactly what i wanted to do
not only as governor but with our
professionals in the state of texas who
deal with human trafficking all the time
learn about who trafficked these kids
into the state who in the state of texas
is involved in this so that we can go
out and arrest them and stop this human
trafficking
this is a crisis that's being made worse
by the fact that the bite administration
is subjecting even more children to
coming to
texas or coming across our border who
are going to be victimized
by these cartels and the cartel gang
members who
could harm these children along the way
just to be clear
they could be subjected to sex crimes
and absolutely if you as the governor of
the state want to look into that you
can't
you can't find that out and help them
exactly so every day in in our office we
have a child
sex trafficking office in the governor's
office in the state of texas
we also have human trafficking
operations in the attorney general's
office
that crack down on crimes like this in
the state of texas
all the time these professionals are
being denied
the ability to crack down on the human
trafficking that these children
are being subjected to on the trek to
the united states
and they're being tracked once they get
here i also wanted to ask you about this
because
we are in the middle of a pandemic and
secretary marcus yesterday at a hearing
basically said they have released
migrants into the country
that have coveted watch there were times
earlier when individuals
were apprehended and we sought to expel
them
and we were unable to expel them and we
were compelled to release them
and we did not have the opportunity to
test them we have addressed that
situation
have they addressed the situation sir
they have begun to however dana this is
another cover-up
and try to cast the blame elsewhere by
the by administration if you kind of go
back
one and two weeks ago the administration
made it sound like it was
my fault as the governor of texas that
these children
and the other people coming across the
border were not being tested i said it
is the biden
administration's responsibility to do
this now mayorkas and other bite
administration officials are
acknowledging the fact
that there are people coming across the
border who are being released and
remember this
one of the greatest challenges we're
facing with regard to the pandemic right
now
are all these different variants one of
the
variants is coming from brazil are there
others coming from elsewhere
we need to know exactly which countries
all of these
people are coming from what variance
they may have been exposed to
how many people are testing positive who
are coming across the border
we've tried to contain the spread of
kobe 19 in the state of texas
now the bond administration is importing
more covert into the u.s
that they could be keeping out if they
were securing the border
to be clear governor the biden
administration did not like the policies
on behalf of the trump administration
so they changed them starting on the
inauguration day
and they did it in the middle of a
pandemic does that make sense to you
it's a total disaster it would be a
disaster anytime
but during the time of a worldwide
pandemic and bill remember
that one of the worst countries in the
world before the spread of covert one of
these so-called
red zones and hot zones is mexico
so many of these people are not from
mexico but they travel through mexico
and they would be exposed to
covet in mexico and so what the bite
administration is doing is on the one
hand trying to solve the pandemic in the
united states but
on the other hand import more the
pandemic into our country
that is reprehensible and i will add
they are not stepping up
and providing either the the cova
vaccine test which now they are saying
they're beginning to do
but also think of all the people that
these people who just come across the
border have exposed themselves to
and those people need access to vaccines
immediately and the body administration
is not stepping up providing those
vaccines understood governor thank you
for your time today we're in touch with
you throughout the day
and the weeks to come thank you greg
thank you for that